there's something very interesting going
on with noam chomsky
now chomsky's in his 90s and noam
chomsky has for a long time been a
progressive hero to many on the left
until recently when he started saying
things that sound
to be quite frank more like me uh i'm
often called a neo-liberal shill by some
on the left who think i'm just not quite
progressive enough and noam chomsky is
suffering a lot of the same fate right
now
recently noam chomsky said it's so
important to remove trump
that every bernie supporter should vote
for biden i agree with that noam chomsky
now agrees
a lot of people uh in a sli in a sliver
of my audience were very mad
about noam chomsky saying that chomsky
was recently interviewed by anand giri
daradas who's been a guest on the show
and chomsky again said things that sound
a lot like me
and some people on the left are now
furious with chomsky now one of the
things i've been saying
is that as a presidential nominee for a
major party and as a possible president
joe biden is running to the left of just
about every candid candidacy i can think
of in the modern political era
biden is two obamas left on climate and
on health care
and on financial policy and it makes
sense because it's 12 years later the
country
and the democratic party have moved to
the left so it would follow
that biden is to the left of hillary and
to the left of obama and his campaign
indeed is
and i took a bunch of heat from my
viewers for saying that
some people writing in and saying david
that's meaningless to say biden is the
furthest left because
biden might not be sincere in those
policy ideas
and he might not actually get it done
that applies
to any candidate that's an impossible
criticism to address because you can
apply it to any candidate
we'll now known chomsky has said almost
the same thing
who uh said to anand giridaradas quote
take biden's campaign positions farther
to the left
than any democratic candidate in memory
on things like climate
it's far better than anything that
preceded it
not because biden had a personal
conversion or the dnc
had some great insight but because
they're being hammered on by activists
coming out of the sanders movement and
others
the climate program a two trillion
dollar commitment
to dealing with the extreme threat of
environmental catastrophe
was largely written by the sunrise
movement
and strongly endorsed by the leading
activists on climate change the ones who
managed to get the green new deal
on the legislative agenda that's real
politics
this is a true pragmatic sort
of real politic from noam chomsky and it
actually gets even more pragmatic and
it's fascinating to see chomsky and i
suddenly exactly on the same page
on this issue this next quote is from
the debate over whether biden is
good or merely less bad than trump
and how we should be thinking about that
and anand says to chomsky
this is interesting coming from you your
support for biden is more than merely
grudging
you actually seem to think that the
platform is surprisingly good
given who he is and given where we are
and chomsky responds quote
this is not support for biden it is
support for the activists
who have been at work constantly
creating the background within the party
in which the shifts took place and who
have followed sanders in actually
entering the campaign and influencing it
support for them
support for real politics the left
position
is you rarely support anyone you vote
against
the worst you keep the pressure and the
activism going
chomsky is pointing out it's not new
that the left is in a position
of supporting the least bad it's common
that the left is choosing between
options that are not ideal
or perfect or great and that that's how
progress works and yet
on the one hand sure systemic change has
to come in order to really improve
society i'm with you but another four
years of trump pushes us towards this
bizarre neo-fascism that donald trump
has espoused
even more and and it gives us another
four years
of falling behind on climate and on so
many issues and things will get worse
now some people will say
it's the biden types one after another
you know obama
the hillary candidacy now biden that's
what led to trump
in some fundamental sense
everything that happened before today
led to where we are today the outcomes
are a result of everything that has
happened but it is ridiculous to say
it's only because of the democratic
nominees that we now have trump that's a
silly argument it's indefensible
we also got trump because of
anti-intellectualism
xenophobia racism obama being half black
you know there's this very long list of
factors and there is no evidence that
another
four years of trump in power will
generate the collapse that some on the
left
want to see because they believe it will
usher in
some truly left system of government
there's no evidence that that would
happen
the last four years have proven that
and it's very interesting to hear this
not from me although this sounds like my
monologues from four months ago
uh but from noam chomsky we'll have
continued coverage of this
on the david pakman show instagram david
pakman show and you can follow
me on instagram as well at david.pacman